hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well one position on mortality that the
ancient School set out that is often
criticized by many people afterwards is
that
suicide is acceptable at least in
certain circumstances it's not a blanket
uh endorsement let alone advocacy but
death is placed into a certain
perspective and so in letter number 70
senaka is writing to lilus and
essentially setting out his thoughts on
the matter and he says this is a little
bit into the letter um life is not
always something to hang on to it's not
as if life itself is
automatically a good or a value for the
stoics and why would that possibly be
the case well he tells us that our good
is not just in living by
itself but in Living Well Ben VI not
just Viv so not something to cling to
not something to try to retain no matter
what so that that means that we need to
exercise wisdom or Prudence in thinking
about the circumstances in which a
person or ourselves indeed might say yes
this would be the right course to take
to allow oneself to die or even to take
active measures and so he talks about
the wise person the sapians the person
sometimes called the sage who is a model
for the stoics and he says the wise
person lives as long as he ought to not
as long as he can so there might be some
circumstances under which it makes sense
for the wise person to say I've had
enough of this he considers where he
will be living how with whom and what he
will be doing and then this is sort of a
great sum up he is always thinking about
the quality of his life not the quantity
the quality of life is what really
matters and then uh he says if he
encounters many hardships at banished
Tranquility he releases himself nor does
he do so only in the extremity of need
but as soon as he begins to have doubts
about his his fortunes he makes a
careful assessment to determine whether
it is time to quit now we might pause on
that and say well wait a second son the
stoic wise person is this exalted figure
who can be happy even while being
tortured doesn't have any sort of
desires or commitments to things that
don't really
matter why would they be bothered and
and so you know you could say well maybe
he doesn't mean that superlative capital
w wise person maybe he means a person
who has some measure of the virtue of
wisdom or Prudence but isn't completely
there and knows that they're going to
run into difficulties or problems sooner
or later that are going to as he says
upset their
Tranquility now here going on a little
bit further it's a matter of
indifference to this wise person whether
he brings things to an end himself or
only accepts the end that comes whether
it happens sooner or later he doesn't
fear the end as if it were some terrible
loss so he's got courage as well uh no
one can lose much when it's only a
driblet and so this is going to lead us
to another thing that is is being
stressed
here it's a question of dying well sort
of like living well or dying now notice
the other qualifier
badly you can just I suppose just die
but you get the idea that for senica
it's kind of one or the other you're
going to die badly or you're going to
die well and he says that dying well is
actually escaping the risk of living
badly right so he says um you know we
don't want to just have hope for Hope's
sake talks about this guy who'd been
thrown into a cage was being fed like a
wild animal when someone urged him to
stop eating that is to you know kill
himself he said well life endures all
hopes remain and senica says well okay
maybe that's true but that's not a great
line of reasoning life is not worth
buying at every price like demeaning
yourself to the level of being treated
as an animal and then he's going to
consider a number of different possible
stances that we could take and some of
these may seem you know a bit
contradictory to each other so the first
thing that he talks about is he says
there are times when even if certain
death awaits and you know the sentence
has been predetermined the wise person
won't lend a hand in his own
execution only if it's in his own
interests will he do so so here's an
example of this um you know Socrates in
his prison cell you know he's been
sentenced to execution he will in fact
kill himself in accordance with the laws
of the city drinking a poisonous
beverage Hemlock which will kill him um
but he could have starved himself
beforehand he could have found other
ways to do himself in and instead he
says well I'll just wait until my actual
end he says it's foolish here's the the
lesson it's foolish to die merely
through fear of death so if your goal is
to escape dying you know uh later on in
a determined way just because you're
afraid of it maybe that's a bad reason
to kill yourself now you know we could
take this back a little bit because a
bit later Saka is going to say if you
have to choose between a death Through
Torture and you know a death that you
impose upon yourself it's kind of
reasonable to kill yourself rather than
to have to go through torture and some
of the other examples that he gives
where somebody is uh in a
gladiatorial contest or they're being
taken somewhere as a slave and they
choose to kill themselves they're saying
well you know rather than living badly I
am going to allow myself myself to be
killed or I find a way to kill myself so
you know that's that's one possible
stance that you could take you could say
um I'm not going to you know do myself
in and he's got this example of
scribonia uh the ant of drusus Libo a
young man who is as stupid as he was
Wellborn very ambitious more so than
anyone could be in that period and more
than he should have been in any period
so he's a guy who's vicious right Vice
of of over ambition he was sick and had
been carried from the senate in his
litter all of his relatives had deserted
him um he began to take counsel whether
he should commit suicide or whether he
should wait and scbon said to him why
does it please you to do another's
business you're going to die quick
enough why kill yourself ahead of time
uh he does in fact kill himself and he
says when one is bound to die in three
or 4 days at an enemy's beh Hest
remaining alive is doing another's
business so that's one way you could
look at it and you know then he talks
about the death by torture and he says
you know why not put out your hand and
take the non- tortured death he says if
I were getting ready to sail I'd pick
out a ship if I were getting ready to
move in somewhere I'd pick out a house
just so if I were going to die I would
choose my manner of my death and he says
in the same way long duration not itself
make life better um long duration does
make death
worse and in death more than in other
things we ought to make he says
allowances for temperament now the word
that's being translated there is
temperament could also be translated as
character it's mores which is a plural
and this literally means our customs or
habits the things that make us the kind
of people who we are so it's not just
temperament and like well you know some
people feel this way and some people
feel this way some people are naturally
happy some people are naturally angry
that's not what he's talking about he's
talking about the habits that we've
built up within ourselves he also talks
about following inclination impetum
right uh the phrase there is is actually
um let a person make his exit according
to his own
inclination whether he prefers the sword
or The Noose or some poison let him go
forward with it and break the bonds of
servitude and then he says something
else that's really quite extraordinary
so when you live your life should be
something that you actually can take
satisfaction in should be pleasing to
you and it should also be pleasing to
other people if other people are looking
at you and like well that guy's a
scumbag I don't like having him around
that's a and there's probably something
wrong with the way that you're
living death is not like that he says
the only person you have to please in
your death is you now we could perhaps
think of some exceptions to this but
it's actually a pretty good idea he says
the best death is the one that that
person
prefers it's foolish to think one now
notice what will people say one person
will say I did not act courageously
enough another will say I was too rash
so they're in a controversy about you
know was courage actually shown or not a
third will say another kind of death was
braver let's pause on this for a second
you can't please everybody and if you're
trying to please people through the way
that you die that's kind of a bad way to
end things because you're not going to
be around when they're complaining about
you or praising you or anything like
that this is your last thing so make it
your own senica would say in in these
sorts of cases and he says reputation
has no bearing on the decision you now
have in hand the only goal is to escape
Fortune's grasp as quickly as you can
and what is escape Fortune's grasp this
wild world that we live in where things
are
unpredictable and there's no you know
cause and effect rewarding ver virtue
and uh punishing Vice in in consistent
ways you know you do have control over
what's within your domain your power
what's up to you um the other things you
don't control you don't control how
people are going to view your death you
don't control what they're going to make
of it even if they'll know about it at
all and he does consider an objection
which you could say comes up in in
Plato's fedo to a certain
extent it's wrong to kill yourself you
shouldn't do that he says you'll find
some people even some committed
philosophers who say that one should
never take violent measures against
one's own life why because then you
become your own murderer you should wait
for the end that nature has decreed and
sonaka says they're blocking the road to
Freedom they are actually getting in the
way
of what Nature has decreed of all the
things that Eternal law has done for us
this is the best we have one way into
life birth and many ways out am I to
wait for the cruel action of disease or
of a person when I could pass through
the midst of my torments shake off my
adversities and depart and he says we we
can't complain about life because it
doesn't hold anyone by force if you want
to kill yourself you can't The Human
Condition is he says well situated and
that nobody is miserable except by his
own fault if it suits you live if not
you're allowed to return to where you
came from nonbeing your body can break
down into its elements and then become
other things that's you know allowable
for you so it's not that nature is going
to get ticked off at you if you kill
yourself Nature's just gonna chew you up
and put you back into the hopper and
make other natural things out of you
right so here then he talks about uh our
priorities and he says you've endured
bloodletting to relieve a headache
sometimes people sever a vein as a way
of losing weight there's no need of a
great wound that splits open a the chest
a lanet opens that the way to that great
Freedom a Nick buys your Tranquility if
you want to die it's totally up to to
you and it's easy enough for you to make
that happen it's merely a question of
what your priorities are what do you
value what do you care about what do you
place higher and what do you place
lower so he says listen if you're
Desiring things Without End you're going
to really desire life because that's the
only way you can experience it so what
do need to do he says we need to prepare
ourselves for death and he uses terms
like rehearsal or practice and this is
what the stoics actually did do senica
refers to these stoic
practices sometimes called pre Medio
malorum you know thinking about bad
things in advance death is one of those
things sometimes people like to talk
about momento Mori they love the Latin
phrase senica nowhere uses momento Mor
that's a later phrase that comes in but
it's the same idea be conscious of the
fact that you're going to die I mean you
can think about other things as well
that can be scary that can be oppressive
he says with other things we may perhaps
to have practiced them in vain we can
prepare our mind against poverty sakica
is a great example of this he's Rich his
entire life he does voluntary you know
days of poverty living like a poor
person but you know it never actually
winds up being what he has to do because
he dies at the order of
Nero um we can uh steal ourselves to
disregard pain and be lucky enough to
have sound and healthy bodies that never
demanded any proof of our courage a
little less likely if we live long
enough um we have taught ourselves to be
brave in facing the loss of those who we
love and if we're lucky our loved ones
stay
alive but we're going to die there is no
escaping death so if you're going to
prepare for these other things why in
the hell aren't you preparing for the
one thing that you can be guaranteed you
are going to run into although probably
not experience all the way to the end
and so he also talks about another major
consideration so the stoics as well as
other ancient philosophers liked using
the examples of people who did this well
and senica is going to talk about two
kinds of people the Great Men for
example KO he brings he's already
brought up Socrates he brings up the
skios and people like that uh these are
people whose Deeds we habitually admire
and they've been elevated Beyond
imitation right and senica says you know
that's good that's actually not that
helpful let's think about more Ordinary
People Who as it turns out aren't that
ordinary because they rise to the
occasion they end up
displaying bravery or courage fortitudo
they are Fortis in Latin who are
examples like this well he talks about a
you know rather disgusting act and a
little apologizes a little bit for it
there is a German who go goes off to the
toilets during the preparations for the
morning show and he takes uh back then
they didn't have toilet paper so they
would take a sponge that was attached to
a stick and that's what you'd clean
yourself with and everybody else would
clean themselves with he takes it shoves
it down his throat and exfat himself or
chokes himself to death right that's
pretty gross but it's successful he
kills himself and what does senica say
say about this what a brave man he was
worthy to be granted a choice in his
fate how boldly would he have used a
sword how courageously would he have
thrown himself over a jagged Cliff or
into the depths of the sea with no
resources from anywhere he still found a
way to provide his own death his own
weapon any one of us could do that any
one of us can find Myriad Ways to Die to
kill ourselves right um he gives a few
other examples of a man who's being uh
dragged off to
slavery and
um uh here we go uh a man consigned to
the morning spectacle was being conveyed
there in a wagon surrounded by guards he
let his head sink lower till he could
get it between the spokes of the wheel
and then he allows the wagon to break
his neck another ingenious way of using
what's available in the environment uh
he talks about a barbarian who's given a
lance a spear to fight in a naval battle
and he's like why the hell am I going to
kill these guys for those people up
there I'll just kill myself and Sonica
is not saying we all have to be quite so
dramatic in this but if you want to die
as he's going to say nature Keeps Us in
a prison Without Walls we're in a prison
but we can go anywhere we want we can
pick up anything that we would like to
so he says if desperate characters and
criminals have such a spirit won't
people who've been prepared against
Misfortune preparing ourselves for death
by long practice and re and by reason
the ruler of all things reason teaches
us there are many ways of getting to Our
Fate but the end is the same what is the
end the harbor that we're going to slip
into eventually at the end of our Voyage
death and so he says since it's coming
it doesn't matter when it begins the
same reasoning advises you to die in the
way you prefer if you have the
opportunity but if not to do so in
whatever way you can grasping any
available means of doing violence to
yourself it's wrong to steal the means
notice where he ends of living this
contrast but very fine to steal the
means of dying and so he says we need to
learn how to die and we need to learn
how to die well and this is an integral
part of Living Well dying well and
living well go together they're not
absolutely opposed to each other as many
people think and this is really the
Orthodox stoic position that senaka is
conveying here to his interloc and to us
his
readers